a lot I don't know how much you know  about her but the Pick Me label oh yeah  so do you I'm guessing you get called  you know a woman hate or a pick me what  do you think about that oh well okay  first of all I was like what the hell is  a pygmy and so then there it's like  basically you say things so men will  pick you yeah but I'm like I just say my  thoughts I clearly am not that filtered  you know what I mean like I clearly like  sometimes I should say less I  I saw you yesterday at a show and you're  like the whales came for me and I'm like  she's talking about fat people yeah yeah  yeah sometimes my manager's like yeah  yeah so first of all second of all I'm  like pygmy that's the insult that you  want to get married yeah I want to get  married like